[Musica]
tre anni fa ero laureata avevo un lavoro
ben pagato lavoravo in ufficio a
bruxelles
abitavo in una grande città finalmente
il mio grande desiderio un ragazzo
stupendo almeno due viaggi all'anno se
vedevo un bel vestito in vetrina
me lo compravo teoricamente avevo la
ricetta del successo è teoricamente
dovevo essere felice
eppure ero insoddisfatta ogni mattina
suonava la sveglia alle 6 00 e senza
nemmeno alzarmi dal letto mi dicevo ho
volutamente a volte a voce la mia vita
fa schifo vi è mai successo
oltre ad essere insoddisfatta ero
confusa nella testa avevo le solite
domande cosa voglio fare nella mia vita
che cosa mi piace qual è il mio stile
dove vorrei vivere che lavoro fare qual
è la mia passione
abbiamo così tanta scelta oggi che ci
sentiamo persi io ero decisamente persa
anche se non sembrava continuare così
non era un'opzione non lo volevo
accettare anche se non avevo idea di
cosa fare è rassicura ci fosse una
soluzione dovevo stato trovarla non
pensavo a cosa succederà se cambierò e
fallirò pensavo sola cosa succederà se
non cambierò il mio percorso ha inizio
con un bel decluttering dell'armadio
decluttering significa togliere il suo
perso eliminare la confusione e implica
lasciar andare tutto ciò che non si usa
e si ama veramente e fortunatamente al
mio ragazzo non piaceva a metà di quello
che avevo e così sono riuscito a
liberarmi di tutte quelle cose che
portavo che mettevo perché ce le avevo
non perché mi piacevano davvero perché
mi stavano bene mi facevano sentire bene
a mio agio che tenevo per non si sa mai
questo primo passo così semplice perché
si tratta solamente di vestiti non è
stato per nulla semplice anzi lasciar
andare qualcosa di mio
si è rivelato più difficile di
quello che credevo provare per credere
questo primo passo però mi ha insegnato
mi ha fatto capire cosa significa
lasciar andare ad entrare nell'ottica
non devo tenere tutto solo perché cielo
le cose che possiedo devono svolgere una
funzione per me oppure devono portare
valore o gioia alla mia vita questo
primo passo ne ha fatto capire che se ho
solo ai miei vestiti migliori sono
sempre vestita con i miei vestiti
migliori e le ho pensate se potesse
applicare questo metodo ad ogni ambito
della mia vita
se potessi passare il mio tempo solo con
le persone migliori che mi aiutano a
diventare una persona migliore a fare
attività che adoro che mi riempie di
felicità non quelle che sembrano più
giuste per me al momento ma quelle che
mi fanno sentire davvero bene sarebbe
fantastico no nel quasi irreale
eppure è possibile grazie a decluttering
iniziare prima con i vestiti e poi con
gli oggetti attorno a me mi ha aiutato a
fare del the club
un'abitudine che piano piano applicato
ad ogni aspetto ambito della mia vita
le domande che mi faccio spesso sono mi
serve lo voglio veramente come mi sento
ad avere questo cassetto questo mobile
sempre pieno non so mai con cose quando
cerco qualcosa non lo trovo come torno a
casa dopo aver fatto quella attività e
dopo aver visto quella persona cosa
vorrei fare di più e cosa vorrei fare di
meno
potrebbero sembrare tante domande ma non
è qualcosa da fare in un giorno anzi è
decisamente un percorso a volte
difficile ma non impossibile
e decisamente liberatorio che ti porta a
diventare consapevole di ciò che ti
circonda di come passa il tempo e con
chi perché non si tratta solo di vestiti
oggetti ma anche di attività di persone
di cibo e di pensieri questo è il
percorso verso il minimalismo
il minimalismo e mi ha fatto capire cosa
è veramente importante per me ed
eliminare tutto il resto a capire quali
sono le mie priorità è di introdurre più
consapevolezza e intenzionalità nella
mia vita
il minimalismo e mi ha fatto capire che
io non sono il mio passato ma che ciò
che possiedo alla capacità di tenermi
nel passato cioè che possiedo puoi
diventare un peso che mi rallenta e
lasciando andare il passato posso
concentrarmi sul presente
posso diventare chi voglio posso
cambiare il mio futuro perché il domani
dipende dalle scelte che faccio oggi
posso cambiarlo come desidero io e
lasciar andare quindi mi ha aiutato ad
essere mi ha aiutato ad essere aperta al
cambiamento a non essere più ancorata al
passato
il minimalismo mi ha aiutato a lasciar
andare per ottenere la libertà di essere
chi sono veramente
a me piace pensare che sia un percorso e
di libertà ci libera lo spazio ci libera
la mente ci libera il tempo per
permetterci di focalizzarci su ciò che è
veramente importante per noi che sia la
salute la famiglia i figli
una passione il raggiungimento di
obiettivi in particolare e li liberi dal
superfluo
comincia la nostra vita vera
e così è stato per me eliminando per
prima i vestiti poi gli oggetti attorno
a me attività alcune persone i vecchi
ricordi pensieri negativi e limitanti ho
fatto chiarezza su cosa mi piace cosa mi
fa sentire bene soddisfatta poi ho
lasciato il lavoro che facevo e infine
il paese dove abitavo ora mi sento
felice e grata per tutto quello che ho
la mia casa la mia piccola famiglia è
quello che faccio quotidianamente ma se
sono riuscita a farlo a raggiungere
questo stato è perché ho lasciato andare
molto altro ho lasciato andare i pesi
posso dire chi è il minimalismo e mi ha
salvata ma se dovessi rispondere alla
domanda qual è la differenza tra la
media allora è la media adesso e direi
il coraggio di cambiare grazie
[Applauso]